We are first introduced to Dante Bishop on
March 21st 2022 in Southern California.
He’s homeless and he’s being stalked by
a group of Purgers who describe themselves
as fine young very educated guys and gals.
They wear creepy brown masks and fancy clothes.
It’s not known why they target him, but
it’s entirely possible that being homeless,
he thought he’d fare better hiding in an
upscale residential neighborhood whose residents
are less likely to be on the streets for their
Purge, than those in the inner city, but his
assumption was sadly mistaken when he encountered their group, and just happened to be
the first homeless person they came across.
They have a mission to take out the homeless
and the lower class because wiping out that
demographic means paying less on taxes that
support things like food stamps and homeless
shelters.
It’s clear based on the way they talk about
him, that they look down on the homeless.
“The man you are sheltering is nothing but
a dirty homeless pig.
A grotesque menace to our just society who
had the audacity to fight back.”
So when the group encounters Dante, they see
that he’s homeless and they go after him,
but things don’t go as expected.
To learn about how Dante’s experiences that
night were instrumental in putting a stop
to The Purge once and for all, stick around
to the end of this video.
Welcome to Horror History.
Today’s episode will break down one of the
most unlikely characters to become a hero
in the world of The Purge.
When he was first introduced, Edwin Hodge’s
character only spoke on maybe four separate
occasions and was known in the credits simply
as Bloody Stranger.
Then in Anarchy, he makes a small appearance,
but this time he isn’t bloody, so he’s
credited as The Stranger.
It isn’t until the third movie that we learn
who he is and how his experiences changed
history.
So, to understand his story, let’s take
it back to just before he shows up for the
first time in the series.
Surrounded by this strange group of gussied
up Purge participants, he surprises them by
fighting back.
He probably did this with knife he had with
him, and he actually manages to “purge”
one of them.
After doing this, he runs for it.
I imagine the purgers were too busy tending
to their friend to bother going after him
right away, but they would soon follow him
with revenge in mind.
Dante runs down the street in a gated residential
community and tries to call out for help to
the local residents.
“Help me!
Someone please help me!”
His prayers are answered when the Sandin household
lifts their security and a young boy yells
out to him.
He makes a sprint for it and manages to slide
under the closing door just in time.
He may be safe from his original attackers,
however, for all he knows, the Sandin family
is also looking to purge him.
They have blue baptisias outside, a sign that
they support The Purge, but not necessarily
a sign that they participate in The Purge
themselves.
Taking the shelter is Dante’s best bet,
but he still has to stay on his toes.
It quickly becomes apparent that this kid
is the only one reason he was let inside when
the parents emerge in a state of anger and
confusion.
The dad slowly draws his gun on Dante, but
his focus is diverted when a young man on
the stairs opens fire on Mr. Sandin.
The distraction gives Dante a chance to escape
and hide in the house.
He’s probably planning to try to avoid the
family until The Purge ended the next morning,
but he realizes the family isn’t his only
concern when the power is cut in the entire
house.
As he’s searching for a spot, he nearly
gets caught when Mr. Sandin shines a flashlight
on him with his gun drawn.
The darkness works to Dante’s advantage
here, and he’s able to disappear once more.
He ducks out behind a couch in a living room
when he’s approached by a strange drone
shaped like a creepy deformed baby doll.
When it spots him, nobody comes running to
his location to capture him, so he’s intrigued
by what it’s purpose is and decides to follow
it, perhaps thinking it was being controlled
by the boy who let him inside.
If that was his logic, he would have been
correct.
It leads him into a closet where he discovers
a hidden area covered up by a panel, and he
takes refuge there just before Mrs. Sandin
enters the room.
She searches the closet, and he readies his
knife, but ultimately is not discovered.
That doesn’t last long however, because
the Sandins’ daughter Zoe also tries to
hide there, and not wanting to kill anyone,
Dante has no choice but to take her hostage.
The threat doesn’t really work out for him
though, because he was never going to shoot
Zoe, he’s not violent by nature and killing
her wouldn’t get him anywhere.
In a stand-off with Mr. Sandin, he explains
that he doesn’t want to hurt any of them,
but he deserves to survive the night just
as much as they do.
He finds out that the purge group he escaped
from has threatened the Sandins’ lives if
they don’t turn him back over.
Meanwhile, Mrs. Sandin sneaks up behind him,
and he has to abandon his plan.
He throws Zoe into the wall and tries to run
for it, but he’s brought down by Mr. Sandin.
He flails and struggles, but is forced to
cooperate when Mr. Sandin restrains him and
his wife brutally cuts into his wound with
a letter opener.
Dante is duct taped to a chair where he sees
how much turmoil he is causing the family
and concedes his struggle.
“Save your children.
Take me outside.”
It is perhaps this humility, that causes Mr.
Sandin to decide he’s had enough of being
pushed around by the purgers outside the house.
He leaves Dante in restraints upstairs unsupervised,
giving him time to wiggle out and free himself.
Once again, he hides somewhere in the house,
as he hears the Sandin family fight for their
lives and his own.
At some point, he must have felt guilty for
hiding while the man who risked everything
for him, a stranger, was being massacred downstairs,
and he decides he’s going to return the
favor.
The other neighbors take care of the threat
of the masked purge group, but only because
they want to take out the Sandins themselves.
Dante finds himself a weapon and the controller
for the creepy baby drone, and just as the
neighbors are about to sacrifice the family,
he runs the RC vehicle across the foyer to
distract everyone, allowing him to get into
position to go to town on the neighbors -- knocking
the first one out with fist, taking out another
with his gun and grabbing the woman, Grace,
as a hostage.
He forces the remaining neighbors to drop
their weapons and untie the remainder of the
family, but once they are safe, he refuses
to engage in any more violence.
He watches over everyone as they all sit at
the kitchen table and wait for The Purge to
expire.
After the sirens sounds, Dante is the last
to leave.
He places the gun on the table, and when Mary
thanks him for saving them all he can muster
is…
“Good luck.”
The psychological damage of the horrors he
experienced that night would change the course
of the rest of Dante’s life.
He had seen first hand what The Purge was
doing to his country, and his new mission
would be to put a stop to it.
Sometime over the next year he joins an anti-Purge
revolutionary group headed up by a man named
Carmelo Johns.
Carmelo’s thesis is that The Purge is a
tool to funnel wealth upward to the NFFA political
party through killing.
He aims to educate people about that and protect
those who would be victims.
This makes it a perfect organisation for Dante
to be a part of, given that his lack of wealth
in 2022 gave him no way to protect himself,
and that nearly resulted in him being purged.
“This year, we will fight back!”
During the 2023 Purge, Carmelo’s group hacks
into the NFFA countdown stream at the 6-hour
mark and issues a propaganda warning, claiming
that their message will be written in the
blood of their opponents.
This shows us that Dante’s views have changed
since the previous year, where he was only
willing to engage in violence for survival
purposes.
This year he’d be coming fully armed.
The anti-NFFA revolutionary group led by Carmelo
Johns spends their 2023 Purge trying find
and break up an NFFA Purge Night Gala, where
rich political donors have the option to buy
into a controlled environment where they can
shoot down unarmed victims for sport.
Dante is a part of this mission, which requires
him to break one of the few laws upheld during
The Purge: using weapons class 5 and above
-- in this case explosives that helped them
gain entry to the building.
“The use of explosives higher than class
four is prohibited on Purge night.
You will be prosecuted.”
Dante leads the way, striking down the NFFA
security guards and announcing to the victims
that they’re here to help and that they
should hold their fire.
He’s also the first one to reach them and
explain who they are, and what they’re doing
there.
EVA: “Who the f*** are you?”
DANTE: “Nobody special.
Just some people who don’t necessarily agree with The
Purge is all.”
He recommends that they get out before things
get nasty, and Carmelo’s group forms a line
and combs the room, taking out everyone associated
with the NFFA.
Since Dante’s identity was not covered,
it’s likely that he had to go into hiding
to avoid being arrested for his use of high
class explosives.
It may also be possible that it was too dark
in there for any cameras to pick up his identity,
or that he actually was prosecuted for illegal
use of explosives but was eventually released
from prison, however I find that idea pretty
unlikely based on the fact that in the world
of The Purge, trespassing after the sirens
sound gets your the death penalty.
It’s hard to imagine the penalty for using
illegal weapons would be any less.
It is not known what happened to Carmelo Johns,
but at some point, Bishop assumes leadership
of the anti-NFFA militia and brings on a man
named Angel to be his second in command.
During his time in charge of the organization,
he sets up a series of underground triage
centers staffed with doctors and medical supplies
meant as an alternate form of protest against
what goes on during The Purge.
He also invites the homeless to take shelter
there, likely in honor of Charlie Sandin who
offered him shelter when he was on the streets.
Seventeen years after breaking up the gala,
Dante finds himself in Washington DC at the
heart of the protest against the Purge in
the year 2040.
The NFFA this year is facing the greatest
threat to The Purge yet, because a new political
candidate named Charlie Roan has gained enough
popularity to threaten the NFFA’s regime.
That’s why Dante has taken his talents to
the nation’s capital, where he gives a statement
on the 11 o’clock news.
“For the past 20 years, the NFFA has taken
a legalized murder to decresase the poor population,
which in turn keeps the government spending
down.
Less welfare.
Less healthcare.
Less housing.”
Feeling threatened by Senator Roan, the NFFA
institutes a new law that removes the exemption
for high ranking government officials.
Just as Dante once tried to use the Sandin
family’s own weapons against them, he sees
this as an opportunity to take out the NFFA’s
next presidential candidate: Edwidge Owens.
He watches a presidential debate where he
learns that Owens will be spending this year’s
Purge at a part religious cult / part political
cult ceremony called the Midnight Purge Mass,
and Bishop and his team of revolutionaries
plan to break in and assassinate him, ensuring
Roan the presidential victory.
BISHOP: “The NFFA has created predatory capitalism.
Profit making is the essence of democracy.
We’ve come to DC to make some changes.”
On Purge night, Bishop’s base of operations
is in one of the underground triage centers
which is supposed to be secure because only
the triage van drivers know its location.
“We call this a safe zone.”
Bishop gets word that an attempt was made
on Senator Roan’s life and that she’ll
be taking refuge in his safe zone.
He shows her around, helps her get settled
in and vows to use his armed men to keep her
safe.
She does thank him for his protection, but
also confronts him about some of the “tactics”
he employs on Purge night that she doesn’t
agree with.
She’s probably referring to the group’s
tendency to fight violence with violence.
He tells her that if she gets elected and
puts an end to Purge night, he won’t have
to do those things anymore.
However, he’s not planning on leaving the
results of that election up to chance.
This plan gets exposed when Senator Roan’s
private security detail, Leo Barnes, one of
the men that Bishop saved in 2023, goes behind
closed doors and discovers their plot to take
down Edwidge Owens.
Roan vehemently objects, claiming that her
opponent must survive to lose the election,
otherwise he may become a martyr and risk
further civil retaliation.
NFFA soldiers discover and storm the safe
zone, looking for Dante, but he’s already
gone when they arrive.
He and his men are infiltrating a secret underground
tunnel into the cathedral where Owens’s
Midnight Purge Mass is being held.
They encounter an unexpected ally.
It’s Leo Barnes, the man in charge of keeping
Senator Roan alive.
He explains that she’s been kidnapped by
the NFFA, that this is now a rescue mission.
Barnes and his allies join Dante’s team
in the invasion.
They split up so that Barnes takes the vantage
point at the balcony and Bishop and his men
enter from behind the altar.
Barnes’s people are able to get off the
perfect shot to save the senator, but they’re
countered by a wave of secret service agents,
which Dante and his people catch by surprise
by coming up behind them.
It looks as if he may have remembered something
he learned 18 years ago at the Sandin house.
His troops also capture minister Owens, and
Roan begs him to reconsider taking out her
political rival.
“I can win without this, please.”
“You will win.
I’m gonna make sure that happens.”
When she tries to say that going through with
it will make him no different than the NFFA,
he tells his people to seize her, which leads
to a stand off between Barnes and Bishop.
He brushes her off and goes into the room
where Owens is being kept.
At this point the minister is encouraging
and begging him to Purge him, knowing that
the political ripple effect of his death would
benefit the NFFA.
Dante finds himself on the other end of the
situation he was in in 2022, and like his
captor Mr. Sandin, Dante makes the decision
not to use violence to lower himself to the
level of the purgers and his parting words
to Roan are that she better win that election.
They continue on to the next chamber where
Owens has dozens of prisoners who would have
been purged if Midnight Purge Mass had not
been broken up, but Bishop is more concerned
with leading the charge out of the church
to get Roan to safety.
They make it to the parking lot, where they
come up against a group of mercenaries led
by the neo-Nazi NFFA henchman Earl Danzinger.
Danzinger’s squad completely overpowers
them in terms of firepower -- he has several
men firing away with big automatic weapons.
They take out two of Dante’s top guys and
shoot him in the hand.
Leo comes to his aid, and Dante asks him to
cover him while he tries one last move.
He hotwires a car and floors it across the
garage to take out two of the evil mercenaries,
but as soon as he does so, he is shot dead
by Danzinger.
It is likely that without Dante Bishop’s
heroics, Leo and the others would have had
no chance to defeat Danzinger, get Senator
Roan and Edwidge Owens to safety and ultimately,
two months later on May 26th, defeat the NFFA
in the presidential election and finally put
an end to the nationwide Purge after at least
23 years.
Was Dante Bishop perfect?
Not by any means.
Right from when we first meet him he’s a
killer, but we can see at the beginning it’s
only out of desperation to survive and he
does everything he can to avoid unnecessary
death.
That night, he takes one more life in order
to save three innocent ones.
However, he does let the experience shape
him in a negative way.
The following Purge he once again saves a
group of people, but he allows Carmelo’s
vengeful ways to influence him and he stays
behind to do more fighting rather than help
the survivors get to safety.
In the years that would follow, it’s implied
he does a lot of good with his organization
by helping the injured and the homeless, but
gets a mixed reputation based on how he goes
about things.
Also, we can’t just look past the fact that
he just automatically knew how to hotwire
a car.
He’s obviously up to some shady stuff, but
overall he did have good intentions and he
played a vital part in stopping the NFFA and
The Purge.
If he and Carmelo hadn’t saved Leo Barnes
in 2023, Leo never would have been able to
protect Senator Roan in 2040.
And if he hadn’t sacrificed himself in 2040,
who knows if she would have survived?
Let me know if the comments if there are any
other Purge characters you’d like to see
covered here on Horror History.
And if you love The Purge, I’ve got plenty
more Purge videos on the way, so check out
that playlist on the left and remember to
subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every
week, ring the deathbell for notifications
and I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.
And just like the Purge, I recommend you stay
home, but if you have to go out, wear a mask.